た↑ら↓たった
たらたたたら
ぷぉ〜〜ん(キューバを吹く音)
た↑ら↓たった
たらたたたら
とぅるとぅ〜〜(クラリネットを吹く音)
かっこかかこっかっこ(木琴を叩く音)
ぴろぴろん♪
こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです。
お前たち、ドライアイスって知ってるか？
ドライアイスとは、固体二酸化炭素の商品名である。固形炭酸、固体炭酸とも言う。ドライアイスは常圧環境下では液体とならず、直接気体に昇華する。また、比重は1.56で、昇華温度は1気圧で−78.5℃である。　同圧条件下では、昇華潜熱は573 kJ/kg (137 kcal)であり、冷却能力は同容積の氷の約3.3倍となることが主な特徴として述べられる。ドライアイスの製造法としては製油所の精製過程、アンモニアの製造過程、ビール工場等の発酵過程などで出る、副産物としての気体の二酸化炭素（炭酸ガス）を用意し、洗浄塔で精製する。
その気体の二酸化炭素を、加圧圧縮した後に冷却して(Wikipediaより引用)
そういった性質を持った、固体のことでございます。(たぶん)
ドライアイスはですね、空気中に置くと、空気中の水分が氷(白い煙)が発生します。
というわけで(？)今日はな、ここに...何キロでしたっけ？
100キロ...？
(失笑)
というわけで今日はですね(2回目)、こちらに100キロのドライアイスを準備したわけなんですけどぉ、
ドライアイスの特性として、こう...摩擦のない床とかに置くと、
スゥゥーーーーーーーー(なめらかさを表現する音)
ってすべるんですよ。
けど俺は思ったんだ、
ドライアイス100キロを準備して俺が乗って、こう...
床を全部摩擦のない床にしてあるんでェ...(嘘)
マァボクガネ？100キロのドライアイスに乗って、
ここに乗ってこう...
(風をきる音)
いくと。(意味深)
こうｽｰｰｰｰってたぶん、全く等加速運動というか、
初速度のまま、このまま直線運動できるような新しいタイプの乗り物が出来ると思うので...！
やるよっ
ぴろぴろん♪(場面転換)
はい。というわけで一応安全のためにドライアイスを全体的に覆ったので
一応安全面では大丈夫だと思います。
・・・・・
危ないから真似すんなよぉ？！
はじめ「っていう注意書きをね...？」
スタッフ「そうですね。」
ではいきます。
TWO (perfect pronunciation)
ﾄﾞﾝｯ　　ｷｭｯ
・・・・・・
ちょっと自分の力では無理だったので押してもらいます。
お願いします。(お願いするとはいってない)
グッ
ドライアイス「・・・・・ 」
はじめ「・・・・・・・」
スッタフ「・・・・・・・」
ｽｯﾀｶﾀｯｶｶｽﾞｯﾁｬｶﾁｬｯﾁｬ
ﾄｩﾝﾀｶﾄｩﾄｩｯ
ﾄｩﾝﾀｶﾁｬｯﾁｬﾗ
ｽｯｯ！
ｽｯﾀｶﾀｯｶｶｽﾞｯﾁｬｶﾁｬｯﾁｬ
ﾄｩﾝﾀｶﾄｩﾄｩｯ
ｽｩｳｳﾝ
ﾄｩﾝﾀｶﾁｬｯﾁｬﾗ
ﾄｩﾝﾀｶﾄｩﾄｩｯ
ﾄｩｯﾄｩｯﾄｩ
〜♪
おわらない